now overall the economy is weaker in the
UK than in any other European country
but it's also quite clear that at the
moment the diesel discussion and
announced additional taxes on latest
technology have created a reaction in
the consumer base and by the way
proposed the petrol but also the diesel
products and if you can see there's a
statistics you can just see the figures
in front of you it goes backwards in the
UK you've announced during the last
fortnight that you've reduced one of
your production shifts the tale wood as
the result of a falling UK consumer
demand might you have to do more of that
elsewhere across the business if this
kind of trend continues so at the end of
the day we have roundabouts there you
come market you went down by 5.6 percent
last year and also engineer in February
went on further diesel is down by 23 24
percent and it's quite clear if there's
no demand then we have to adopt our
production levels so potentially there
could be cuts in production elsewhere in
the UK now at the end of the day we also
have to say we produce for the global
markets and we can balance but it's
unfortunately that in the UK the demand
is not there anymore and the case our
home market so in our home worker it's
important for us that the economy can
grow and that we I want to have a free
opportunity to sell our cars we've
launched the new Jacqui Roy pace how
many do you anticipate selling in the
first year so the response to the I cap
I pace concept is unbelievable we gonna
produce this vehicle in Austria and we
have started the production
last week and we expect really a massive
success out of this vehicle now as you
say it's being built in Austria why
couldn't it have been manufactured in
the UK we had decided and to find this
kind of concept already five to six
years ago knowing that we will not have
any manufacturing capacity in UK at that
time and therefore we had to go abroad
with the vehicle but I really would like
to make it crystal clear Jaguar Land
Rover is and also will be a British
company our design our engineering our
research is in the UK and we will stay
there and of course you want you to make
a decision later this year on whether
you will build electric cars in Britain
what are the kind of factors that you're
weighing up at the end of there we have
to make sure that we can have free fair
and very transparent trade that all this
kind of regulations can be managed very
well so that the complete export
industry so not only we as OEM but also
the suppliers find the right basis to do
business so ultimately it's contingent
on the government getting the right
brexit deal yes and it is and how
optimistic are you about the the state
of negotiations right now are you
confident that there will be tariff free
movement of manufactured goods within
the UK in the eurozone it's best for the
society it's best for nation really to
work together and therefore encourage
free and fair trade and I hope that
these theories still valid today that
this series also will be valid by
governments on the one on the other side
of the channel
Trump has threatened that if the EU
retaliates against his tariffs on steel
and aluminium imports he will hit
European car exports yes but I only have
heard about aluminium and steel imports
and exports nothing really entitled
about
the kinda Street and so we really have
to look forward to have to get some
ideas on the table then can see together
then can assess the statement and can
talk with a respective partners